[Music]
[Applause]
here's Joe Thomas the Hall of Famer in
fact uh teammate at Johnny Manziel's
what 2014 2015. have you watched the
documentary
no it's crazy getting ready for the Hall
of Fame stuff I feel like I've been
living under a rock because I didn't
even know there was a Johnny Manziel uh
Netflix documentary until one of my
friends asked me if I watched it last
night and I'm a little conflicted like
you I'm not sure if I want to watch it
because I lived it and there's still a
few scabs that I'm peeling off right now
after those Johnny Manziel moments and
so I I don't know I'm a little bit torn
there when did you know that this wasn't
going to work out for Manziel
well shortly after we drafted him he
like vanished in the spring
um like we were in the middle of OTAs
and the coaches couldn't find him he
just he had come to Cleveland he was
there for like a day and he was at
practice and then he just disappeared
and I think he was just on a bender
somewhere in Cleveland partying and he
couldn't find his way back to the
facility and so it was at that moment I
was like we may have some problems with
this young rookie here if he can't even
find his way during OTAs when he's a
rookie when he should be trying to put
his best foot forward
it's got to be tough for you because
you'd been through losing Seasons you
know you're looking for professionals
you're trying to do your job at the
highest level and then you can't even
trust your quarterback how frustrating
is that for you where you're playing at
a All-Pro level and then you got a
no-show level with your quarterback
yeah it's not a lot of fun especially
when you're an old guy and you're still
showing up for mini camps and OTAs and
all the optional stuff in the off season
and here's this first rounder who's
supposed to be doing everything he
possibly can to earn the trust and
respect of his teammates and he's
missing and he can't find him so
um that was really frustrating but I
always wanted to give guys a second
chance give them the benefit of the
doubt early on you know hey maybe he's
still got an opportunity to turn this
around somebody had to see something in
him for us to draft him in the first
round I know he had a great college
career but hey even if he didn't have
the off the field problems when you look
at him as just a prospect he was short
he was not incredibly fast or quick it's
not like he was a short quarterback that
ran a 4-4 and was just lightning quick
where you thought he could make up for
it like he had a ton of physical
limitations that the NFL game was going
to expose and you were wondering like
how is he going to be able to get around
the fact that he kind of has a long wind
up to throw he's not really big so he
won't be able to absorb those hits
um he hasn't really proven that he could
play within the confines of an offense
he was just playing backyard football in
college
um and then he also doesn't have super
athletic ability so you kind of look at
all those things and I'm going man how
is this guy going to ever be able to
figure it out and on top of that he
doesn't really seem all that committed
to being a quarterback
congrats on going into the Hall of Fame
the 2023 class uh your thoughts on Dion
saying what if we have a maybe a
penthouse level first ballot Hall of
Famer yeah is that a big deal that that
there's a gold level maybe uh for those
first battle Hall of Famers
you know I'll let the people that are in
charge of the Hall of Fame and the fans
kind of make those distinct the
determinations and the distinctions and
it almost makes me uncomfortable there
I'm stuttering just talking about it
because being at Canton during the
entrance and seeing all those other gold
jacket guys many of them who were not
first ballot Hall of Famers but guys
that were my Idols growing up that I
revered as players some of them like
LeRoy Butler I just post her on my wall
as a kid he was not a first ballot Hall
of Famer and for me to stand there and
answer questions like yeah I think I'm
more important than uh my guy LeRoy
Butler who by the way he made me cry
when he came up and said congratulations
because he was my hero as a kid it just
makes me uncomfortable talking about
that I know for a guy like Dion hey he's
used to talking about himself so he
probably is okay answering that question
and proclaiming how he's the greatest
and he should have his own uh Closet in
Canton Ohio but for me I'm just so proud
to be one of those gold jacket guys and
whatever they decide to do as long as
everybody feels okay with it I'm good
with it but honestly I don't know if we
want to start tiering players that are
in the Hall of Fame and you grew up in
Wisconsin so you're a Packers fan love
LeRoy Butler I'm curious if you wanted
gave it any thought of playing a year in
Green Bay JJ Watt said to me the other
day that he wanted to go and play one
more year in Green Bay but you know
something happened where he uh they
weren't interested in bringing him back
did you give that any thought
shortly before the Denver Broncos tried
to trade for me in 2013-14 somewhere in
there
um there was some rumors before the the
Packers got David bakhtiari that they
were going to try to trade for me
because obviously they had Aaron Rodgers
and they hadn't yet secured their left
tackle
um but Ted Thompson was the general
manager at the time and he was not a guy
that really made a lot of Trades
um he was just a draft and then
re-signed type general manager and so I
never really put a whole lot of thought
into it but um the once I've retired my
my knee was shot so I couldn't play any
more football however I do think playing
in your backyard especially if you're a
Wisconsin kid like JJ and going and
playing Green Bay the amount of
headaches that you'd have to deal with
with family and friends asking for
tickets and autographs and access like
that would be a headache that would be
far beyond anything that he experienced
in Houston or in Arizona and almost
would be
a big distraction from trying to go out
and play and to the point where I don't
know how much you'd be able to enjoy it
if you were the local boy like JJ or
myself we're talking to Joe Thomas the
Hall of Famer how nervous were you this
weekend
I wasn't overly nervous the thing that
made me the most nervous honestly Dan
was when we got there on Wednesday we
had so many activities and a lot of them
were like cocktail hours where there's a
band plan and you're small talking these
people and you're kind of yelling you're
projecting your voice
um and two years ago I had vocal cord
surgery and so my vocal cords are a
little bit weaker than they used to be
so my ability to project and yell is is
limited and if I do it for like an hour
I lose my voice and so I kept losing my
voice at the end of every day to the
point where I wanted to practice my
speech but going into Saturday I was
afraid to use any extra words then was
absolutely necessary so I only practice
my speech one time before I gave that
speech because I was so worried about
getting up there on Saturday afternoon
and not having a voice and having like
try to sign my speech for people to hear
me um so that was the thing that made me
the most nervous so once I got through
it and I had my voice uh it was pedal to
the metal and I can't wait to celebrate
the rest of the weekend
I don't know if you followed the Eric B
enemy story with the commanders and that
some of the players I guess went to uh
coach Rivera complained about his style
and you know he's intense and in your
face what what works now with today's
football player what kind of style and
he's not even the head coach he's the
offensive coordinator
the style that works in is when you show
a player that you are giving them better
information better game planning and
better coaching than the opponent you're
giving them a game plan where they
legitimately feel like they have an
advantage over their opponent and
they're going to be able to now use all
the ability that's God given to them to
be able to go out and win and succeed
for themselves for their family for
their teammates for their city for their
team that's why we said that Kyle
Shanahan was the best coach I ever had
because when you walked out of his
meetings and you walked onto the field
on Sunday you felt like you were more
prepared and that's the best motivation
that any pro athlete can get and so
really your style doesn't matter whether
you're Bill Belichick whether you're
just a nice softy whether you're Eric
bianomian you're a yeller like none of
that really matters and the players
don't care about any of that what they
care about is you proving that you're
putting them in a better position than
the player that they're going to be
going against yeah but the commanders
are complaining like hey you know what
he's intense he's yelling at us
you're saying that that that shouldn't
matter or doesn't matter like did you
get yelled at uh occasionally I
offensive line coaches are known for
being a little colorful and having a
louder voices than most but I honestly
it's kind of silly the fact that
I saw this morning I was working out and
I saw on TV like Eric the enemy was
yelling at his players and the players
are complaining I was like what so I
would love to know some more details
around okay which players are
complaining are these the guys that are
bums or are these like the starters that
are like really making uh a big deal
about this because to me it's about the
substance of what you say if you're
yelling at me but you're telling me good
stuff I'm gonna listen and pay attention
if you're telling me crap I don't care
if you're yelling or if you're
Whispering I don't want to hear about it
um and so to me it sounds a little bit
soft and a little bit like are we
worrying about the wrong things right
now commanders that you know my coach is
yelling too much like what is he saying
that's what I would really like to know
before I can say that these players need
to Buck Up and tough tough up a little
bit Buttercup or are they legitimately
like having some reasonable complaints
like hey I'm losing the message I'm
losing the coaching because he's so
worried about just berating us
uh the defensive lineman that you would
put in the Hall of Fame who's not there
he'll be there next year Dwight Freeney
that was that was a battle
that was a battle Yeah the the times
that I faced Freeney you didn't sleep
much the night before because you knew
how challenging it was gonna be I knew
what his game plan was going to be right
he's just gonna try to run around you
for a full half he's gonna wear you out
then he's going to try to run you over
and then as soon as you stick your heels
in the ground and you try to make a
stand it'll be like third and eight and
he's going to spin to the inside and
he's gonna sack your quarterback
everybody knew when he was going to do
it everybody knew when it was coming but
you couldn't stop it and that's why I
think he belongs in the Hall of Fame
who who'd you meet aside from LeRoy
Butler this past weekend that you went
oh my God
um it was really cool being able to
reconnect with Anthony Munoz because I'd
seen him a few times and I've worked
with him a few times during my career
but I think now being part of that club
and having that gold jacket it's just a
little bit different when you hang out
with those guys and when you spend some
time I will say oh Jack Youngblood
um going back to the voice problem he
was outside the hotel on Friday
um and he was smoking a cigar and having
like a Heineken it was like 10 30 in the
morning and I'm like man you're really
living the life aren't you and he's like
hey I got a cigar for you buddy and uh I
was like I Can't Have a Cigar yet I'm
watching my throat because I don't want
to lose my voice and cigars are not good
for that but I can't wait to have a
cigar with Jack Youngblood because that
would be so stinking cool not only for
me but for my dad and my father-in-law
and all these like people that I were
looking up to when I was a kid like that
era of the NFL was so cool and all those
guys that went on and were in Hollywood
and they had these Larger than Life
personas and personalities
um it was really cool meeting them and
and just seeing those guys relaxed
smoking a cigar and having a a noon beer
on a Friday afternoon
how challenging is it rooting for the
Browns nowadays
uh it's not challenging for me
um I played there 11 years and I had
Johnny Manziel as my quarterback I had a
lot of other guys that maybe weren't um
fan favorites or maybe had some issues
in their past
um or just didn't play all that well
um but I think for me and I think for a
lot of other Browns fans it's the Browns
and it's the team and that is what we
get most excited about and that's where
our loyalty lies so you don't factor
into Sean Watson at all it just
you're rooting for the Browns as a team
yeah I think that for most bronze fans
myself included like we talked only
about that last year like that was all
we talked about in training camp that's
all we talked about during the season
that's all we talked about after we came
back
um and I think for most of us we're
really excited to talk about DeSean
Watson on the football field because
what happened off the football field
will be dissected and talked about until
the end of days and people will agree
people will disagree but for the most
part it's kind of a dead horse for for
Cleveland people because it's like look
I'm going to cheer for my team and I
know that a lot of people don't agree
with us signing Deshawn Watson but at
the end of the day he's allowed back in
the NFL and the suspension is over he
served his time there and the Browns
were not the only team that were trying
to sign him and I'm sure that if he
plays really well this year a lot of
people will not be thinking about how he
ended up getting there
good to talk to you once again
congratulations and uh we'll be in touch
thank you Joe thanks for having me Dan
that's Joe Thomas Brown's Hall of Fame
tackle